[Music]
in beauty product equality news finally
oh I don't thank God finally finally I
always wanted to [ __ ] use mascara
submitted by um pepperoni nipples that's
me you show us show us being a sniffles
baby oh yeah and when it's hot it gets
bigger is it really like it's red like
when it's called a man your nipples
expand my areolas relax like it's a hot
tub circular anymore like [ __ ] this
it's like a sunflower in the springtime
and [ __ ] opens up it's like those
blooming tea leaves yeah yeah you put it
in hot water just ah it's like a [ __ ]
sea urchin us another example like what
else like taking your straw wrapper
putting a drop of water on it a woman is
suing Walmart over segregated beauty
products beauty products what does that
mean oh you mean like black people
products and white people products I
guess first of all that helps out a lot
really yes because there's a lot of like
very like afro-american centric is that
the PC term that we're looking for here
that's pretty good that's geared towards
black people and there's one is geared
towards white people they have Asian
soaps no but we need agent centric like
products like for example I need a
shaving blade which just maybe like half
a blade on their supply store and all
that stuff too I save like a good 70% of
it is not made for like white people or
Asian people like for example you'll
never see a white person use [ __ ]
sulfur eight you know so hell is that
sulfur AIT's like a medicated a product
that a lot of light black people use
he's like spin around a little kid yeah
didn't ever see if I can wipe up you'll
use
well I use it on my whenever I have fuel
or extra stinky what is sorry the self
rate smells terrible by the way try to
break your stereotypes okay it legit
smells like sulfur really so wait so
what are you using it for
I said hair straightener it's I mean
they have a full line of stuff they'll
have like grease and whatever whatnot
but you'll never see people use [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] do you see a white
person you wait wait actually Wayne
please sometimes wave grease like wave
these are way too good or bad it's a
stop thing oh because I'm thing like I'm
I've seen like on the internet and the
memes and something like oh their ways
are coming in and then like they're
dogging the person I'm a person because
the waves look bad but basically what
happens is you get wave grease what is a
wave by the way okay so if you have
short black people here they'll get a
brush and when you brush it waves come
in oh and it goes like this
exactly okay that happens from like the
waitress and the brushing Oh
clean cut what are you the hair guy oh
he's parents on like a wig shop and
that's why you had the [ __ ] the do
rags or [ __ ] like why don't you have a
cool style for hair David simply because
I don't give a [ __ ] dude that'd be so
dope if your parents always like spout
up all the kids and like corn rolls are
like like whatever you guys were selling
there cuz that would suck they're not
gonna go to a very specific beauty
supply store and then you mix all like
like very specified black beauty
products with everybody's white [ __ ]
it's gonna be hella hard to find dude is
this black no wires is male and female
cuz in Walmart they had that one section
where it's all like my parents door [ __ ]
oh really yeah my brother laughed at me
because I bought the this la looks gel
in a set for his control and I didn't
even know what frizzy hair man I just
bought that gel and I don't know he
thought he was like you don't have
frizzy hair and I know like you got like
studies it is black me what hair right
freezes frizz control well they are
stuff okay well I don't even know what
they what it means smooth yeah like
they're strands kind of sticking out for
his even certain gels to are made for
like thick hair like post I'll gel Pro
style is like this thick black
GUP but it really came like very hard to
manage hair so you'll see girls who have
like the ponytail you see that hairs
like rock hard
that's just post out so what are they
saying now is it coming alive with all
the hair knowledge man where were you
when we needed weave information how was
so confused about the wigs and weaves
yeah black these are black for like
black shampoos and stuff yeah okay what
were they saying like it's a
discriminatory beauty supply cuz it's
only for black people a lot of like a
lot of hair products and a lot of like
companies are actually owned by Korean
people so when my parents came to
America they had to be with the company
that they could communicate with so they
could order supplies why cuz the Korean
people got jungle fever or something we
we actually they have a huge
manufacturing for uh for like wigs
weaves and all the other [ __ ] so you
know like Asian people when there's a
will there's a way to make money so
that's all like in Korea they there
there's an industry for wig
manufacturing exactly Oh gotcha
they did love my back on you think it
Walmart they have a section with like a
few supplies what did it look like like
was it they just had a bunch of black
beauty supplies like just that one
corner how could you tell it was black
beauties because that was black people
on it okay like the models yeah like
there's and it's obviously I'm already
acclimated to those type of products so
like dr. America pro style sulfur eight
all those other shapes oh yeah so what's
happening here is this woman her name is
Essie Grundy she's a 43 year old mother
of five she was shopping Grundy
she sounds a good evil villain oh no oh
every time I see Gloria Allred though I
get a little like oh boy who is that
lady
she's like a ambulance chaser lady
basically yeah she exploits whatever the
hell's going on to her - she's just a
drama queen yeah yeah
lawyer so yeah so then se was saying
that she was shopping at her local
Walmart in Paris California oh I don't
even know there was a Walmart in Paris
yeah so she said that she noticed and
when she walked over to the black beauty
supply section it was all encased oh
like razors man oh I see I thought it
was like just a section behind the glass
you tell us some way all the black
supplies word none of the white supplies
work no so it's like they're all Xboxes
basically right cuz you keep it all
behind so they might as well put like
the bud wires and gates and like I can
attack all of them with like alarm
sounding things like David laughs in the
face of racism okay I used to work at
Target right and the reason why they
start tagging things and doing it is
because of theft
they don't do it first to prevent theft
so like the razor thing right there back
in a day there there wasn't any
it wasn't behind the glass or anything
but it's one of the items that's really
small and easy to conceal but you can
sell it resell it for really high value
because you get like the refillable
razors that they could be like $50 and
they're really easy to slip inside the
pocket so once that became a problem
then they started tagging those and
putting them behind the glass so I
highly doubt that they did that ahead of
time to say like oh these items are
gonna be stolen it's usually a it's a
reaction it's a reaction to to a problem
frequent problem yeah yeah well yeah I
think I have to double check if you go
on the Walmart and like all the
watermelons and Fried Chicken are also
behind like who knows a minute you
depends if they're racist or not if
they're racist and have all those things
in a specific specialty kind of
stereotype yeah it's like yeah it has to
be everything will be a lot of South
Korean people too yep yeah so she was
saying that she was even shocked when
she noticed
she was trying to buy a $0.48 comb but
she still needed to get someone to
assist her to get that comb it was
partition I go through the cracks and
grab the comb I saw it crack you know
what's funny a sign last sometimes only
that let me have one more thing she was
trying to buy a basketball hoop in his
behind laughs sometimes you know those
glass things even they're not even
locked you could just move with that
right dude the razor thing is the most
annoying [ __ ] ever I started buying them
online I got so annoyed by dude the baby
formula they have it to like depending
on the area that you shop at it'll be
closed off condoms do the economist has
always been a thing oh really yeah why I
don't use them that's why I never use
them spray paint is always locked up
because I used to steal spray paint a
lot there you go yeah it was all cause
of me yeah so then she was saying that
you know this is really messed up the
fact that they have all these products
behind these glass partitions because
then it's just perpetuating the racial
stereotype that african-americans are
thieves and she's saying that that's not
fair that they should be treated equal
and that all products should be
available well I hope she understands
that this is a reaction and it's not
that the Stars being racist chicken or
the egg like it's one of those things
where like if it wasn't being stolen
they wouldn't put them in a case exactly
so Walmart and Walmart official they
said this we're sensitive to the
situation and also understand like other
retailers that some products such as
electronics automotive cosmetic and
other personal care products are subject
to additional security those
determinations are made on a store by
store basis using data supporting the
need for heightened measures so what
like I said like I mean just working at
these places I mean I worked at Target
for a couple years and these things are
put into play after the fact that it
gets stolen a lot so I don't think
anyone's going well you guys know black
people they steal all the time so we
just better prevent it by putting a case
on there like I think that's that's deaf
you know it might not even be black
people stealing it it could even be like
Asians that are reselling it at a swap
meet or whatever it's just I like the
swap meet yeah
we probable a lot of stolen goods
actually get resold at swap meets an
ebay contra so that's why it could just
be that these items are like highly
bought at certain locations and it's a
Thieves favorite place to steal so I
think they're taking it a little bit too
personal by saying like oh this is
specifically this is specifically well
but when you can sue my friend a certain
magic comes in the air you know yeah
well I forgot about the suit yeah
yeah and then Gloria Allred swoops in
and just becomes over like a [ __ ]
Technicolor Dreamcoat around you of
majesty I don't know man it's kind of
weird I think people are always gonna
try to target big companies like Walmart
or McDonald's or whatever I just love
the pictures somebody's in there with
Gloria Allred next to them and they like
have tears in their eyes like I've been
so [ __ ] over about something behind
glass like I feel [ __ ] over every time
I try to get a [ __ ] dick razor and
I'm gonna at a drugstore I know exactly
what I'm a higher for her for my
insurance here in the San Gabriel Valley
is way [ __ ] more than anywhere else
were predominantly Asian neighborhood
and everyone knows Asian people got
dressed right that's why we can't drive
we just crash more yep no they're doing
that because that's the stereotypes I
hate that stereotype
[Laughter]
dude Nikki it's so funny when I got with
Nikki she was always like oh he's so bad
at driving or whatever and I was a death
not true I don't always talking about
and then she started driving here know
over years of us driving together so she
he was agency stop the drivers she's
Asian she sucks at driving I'm like oh
my god I stopped it I don't want to see
your point I don't know I don't like
your point I could just she doesn't see
it I do see it and now that I'm an Asian
I can
[Laughter]
Steve lemo that's right I'm a married
Asian so you know yeah water your DNA
that's who I am my kids are gonna be
here so whatever dude
[Music]
[Music]